the british soldier
all around the globe you'll find him
from gibraltar to hong kong
everywhere he stands against the
threatening years
staunch symbol of our common will to
order
so
[Music]
the british empire
the largest empire the world has ever
known
for over 300 years britain ruled its
army is conquered and its bankers
proclaimed the might of its currency
but one day it all began to fall apart
one by one countries declared their
independence from britain
and no amount of force could reverse the
tide
as british elites saw their wealth
privileges and empire disintegrate
they began to search for a new role in a
changing world
and they found one in finance
[Music]
this is a film about how britain
transformed from a colonial power to a
modern financial power and how this
transformation has shaped the world we
live in
[Music]
in the days of the british empire the
city of london was the world's biggest
global financial center
the city of london was the kind of
beating financial heart of the british
empire the historians kanan hopkins
called it the governor of the imperial
engine
all these countries in the empire
used to use the sterling currency and
the city of london was kind of
the financier of this so not just inside
the sterling zone but outside the
sterling zone as well
as britain's empire declined
so too did the city of london
one british army truck is bombed killing
two soldiers and wounding twelve
as rioting becomes daily more widespread
on cyprus young people of high school
age take an increasing part in the
violence here a group of girls are being
dispersed after a rock throwing battle
with british military police
with the decline of empire
british commercial interests across the
globe were under threat
1956 egypt nationalized the suez canal
a new middle east crisis arises as
president nasser of egypt tells a wildly
cheering crowd in alexandria that egypt
has seized the internationally owned
suez canal
france and britain issue a 12-hour
ultimatum within hours of its
exploration britain's war planes are
bringing their way to egypt and its
bombers attacked five key cities
including cairo
the united states was opposed to the
invasion and put pressure on britain and
france to withdraw their troops
there will be no united states
involvement in these present hostilities
it is our open intent
this matter will be brought before the
united nations general assembly
there the opinion of the world can be
brought to bear in our quest for a just
end
to this tormenting problem
britain was humiliated
the suez crisis signified the end of
britain's role as one of the world's
major powers
[Music]
following the crisis there was a run on
the sterling on the uk pound
some people
suspect that the american government was
encouraging this run on the uk pound
as financiers withdrew their money from
britain the value of the pound decreased
to protect the value of the pound
britain limited the bank's overseas
lending
they were not able
to invest abroad and obviously they were
unhappy and we don't know exactly the
context but it's very clear that the
banks or the representative
made a representation to the bank of
england which in itself
was dominated by
representative from the banking industry
it seems that they have reached an
agreement
which
was never written
that if the banks
intermediated between two non-residents
in a foreign currency in that case
dollar that this particular
intermediation this particular deal
will not be considered by the bank of
england under its own jurisdiction
the banks began to create a market for
dollars in london called the london euro
dollar market
to differentiate these euro market
activities from their domestic banking
activities
banks kept two sets of accounts
the bank of england the uk regulator
declared that the london euro market
accounts were not in london they were
elsewhere and therefore it had no
responsibility for regulating them
it's about providing a legal space
in which you pretend activity is taking
place
and the importance of that is that you
pretend it's not taking place
in the economy where it really is taking
place so you're taking activity from the
place where it's regulated and taxed and
pretending that it's happening elsewhere
now where does it really matter it's
just elsewhere
when american banks realized that london
offered the ability to avoid u.s
regulations
they moved their international
operations to the city
[Music]
around the same time as american banks
were moving their international
operations to london
another new kind of financial space
began to emerge
far away from london in britain's
overseas jurisdictions the last remnants
of empire
back in the 60s the cayman islands was a
complete backwater the stories go that
mosquitoes were so thick in the air
sometimes they were enough to suffocate
cows that's a legend that you hear about
the cayman islands i don't know how true
it was but it was there was nothing
happening there
accountants and lawyers from london
arrived in the cayman islands and other
british dependencies and began to draft
a set of financial secrecy laws and
regulations
because these jurisdictions main selling
point was secrecy
they were called secrecy jurisdictions
[Music]
what the cayman islands was doing was
straightforwardly illegal activity
drugs money was coming in in huge
quantities
tax evasion whatever whatever you wanted
you could have it
the bank of england was observing the
developments from london
and noted in a report marked secret
dated 11th of april 1969
we need to be quite sure that the
possible proliferation of trust
companies banks etc
which in most cases would be no more
than brass plates manipulating assets
outside the islands does not get out of
hand
there is of course no objection to their
providing bolt holes for non-residents
but we need to be sure that in so doing
opportunities are not created for the
transfer of uk capital to the
non-sterling area outside uk rules
[Music]
these small territories the last
remnants of the british empire which are
still overseas territories today they
are still the last remnants of the
british empire
there are 14 of these overseas
territories seven of them are bona fide
tax havens including the cayman islands
bermuda the british virgin islands some
of the biggest tax havens in the world
today are still british
[Music]
with access to large amounts of offshore
money the euro market grew rapidly
by 1980 it had reached 500 billion
dollars
by 1988
4.8 trillion dollars and by 1997 nearly
90 percent of all international loans
were made through this market
the british empire had sunk leaving
hardly a trace behind
but the city of london adapted and
survived
the city of london london's financial
district is a peculiar place
it has been called a city within a city
a state within a state
it is run by an organization called the
city of london corporation
a private company that performs all the
functions of a local council with a
private police force and private courts
those of you who aren't from the uk some
of you even who are
might not be aware just how weird a
thing
the little city of london
is within the big city the big london
the city of london is
a separate entity to
uh the wider
london and it has its own uh head the
lord mayor who's distinct from the mayor
who runs the rest of london
every november the city stages the lord
mayor's show the world's oldest civic
procession
[Music]
the city of london has long had this
curious legal status
because
back in 1066 when william the conqueror
came over the city was one of the only
portions of england that he failed to
conquer and he struck a deal with the
city in 1067 that allowed them to
continue functioning
to this day the city of london is exempt
from numerous laws that govern the rest
of britain
its political system derives from the
middle ages
the city's electorate is dominated not
by its residents but by the private
businesses operating within the city
its lord mayor is selected by the heads
of medieval guilds
they have a representative in the house
of commons called the remembrancer apart
from the clerks of the court of the
house of commons he's the only unelected
person there
all other lobbyists have to stop you
know in the lobby they're not allowed
past the lobby
the city of london has a permanent
representative in the house of commons
whose role is to report back to the city
of london corporation
and to lobby parliament on behalf of the
city
the cooperation of london clearly
it's a uniquely unique and interesting
phenomenon that should have attracted
many political scientists political
economies and economists
but i don't know of anyone who has
studied
systematically the corporation in london
and its impact
on policy
or economic policy
so we can only surmise
some people
assume or surmise that the corporation
loan is extremely powerful
and is able in one way or another to
shape
uh british policy particularly within
financial matters clement atlee the
prime minister after the second world
war um
had had something to say about the city
of london corporation he did yeah
so over and over again we have seen that
there is in this country another power
than that which has its seat at
westminster
the city of london a convenient term for
a collection of financial interests is
able to assert itself against the
government of the country
those who control money can pursue a
policy at home and abroad contrary to
that which has been decided by the
people
at the heart of the city of london
stands the bank of england
the bank of england is not just a
central bank it is also a financial
regulator
at the demise of empire
the bank of england used this regulatory
authority to help attract the world's
banks to london
in 1972
the bank of england issued a license to
the bank of credit and commerce
international which set up its head
office in london
within 10 years bcci grew into the
seventh largest bank in the world
ten years later
bcci was bankrupt
the deputy director of the cia richard
kerr said late today that the cia did
use bcci
to support cia activities overseas
but bcci had not just collaborated with
the world's intelligence services
it had also engaged in extensive
financial fraud money laundering and
terrorist financing
bcci constituted international global
crime
of a level that boggles the mind bcci
was financing terrorism the bank of
england knew it says the report but
instead of supervising it properly it
tried to prevent the bank's collapse
i am saying very directly that the bank
of england
had sufficient information in front of
it
to close bcci
15 months earlier than it did but
millions of depositors were hurt in that
process
numerous whistleblowers from bcci had
contacted the bank of england
yet the bank of england did nothing
the bank of england had plenty of time
to intervene and investigate but it did
not do so because the tradition at that
time which still survives is that while
actually you know you have to just kind
of send hints and talk over lunch tables
with the chaps regulating other chaps
and all would be well
robin lee pemberton the governor of the
bank of england at the time of the
collapse of bcci commented
the present system of supervision has
served the community well
if we close down a bank every time we
found an incidence of fraud you would
have rather fewer banks than we do at
the moment
london was a place for banks to engage
in business that was not allowed
elsewhere
where senior bankers did not have to
worry about the consequences of their
actions
this is one of the reasons why today
there are more banks in london than in
any other financial center
in britain nobody goes to jail no
bankers go to jail they generally don't
they are a protected species and that is
part of the offshore business model of
the uk is to say we will protect you we
will bring your money here we will look
after you we're not going to put you in
prison we'll let you do what you want
light touch regulation was one way of
attracting business to london
another was secrecy
from the 1960s onwards city of london
institutions began to establish offshore
branches in former outposts of the
british empire their aim was to create
offshore centers with strong secrecy
legislation in order to attract capital
from across the globe
swiss banking secrecy is the most famous
the most well-known you know putting
money in swiss bank and they won't they
promise not to tell anybody and that's
one kind of secrecy but another kind of
secrecy which is very british is the
trust
and the trust is a very um slippery
complicated
and devious
mechanism trusts emerge the legend has
it from the time of the crusades when
the knights would go off and fight in
foreign lands and they would leave their
assets
in the care of trusted stewards
what trusts do ultimately is they play
with the concept of ownership ownership
is not such a simple thing
so
the settler the knight in this case
would hand over the assets to
someone who
these days would be called a trustee
it's often a lawyer legally you are
separated from those assets they're not
yours anymore there's a barrier
you can't be taxed on them you can't be
nobody's going to find anything about
your connection to these assets
in britain's offshore jurisdictions
no qualifications are necessary to be a
trustee
anyone can set up a trust and act as a
trustee
there is no registry of trusts
there are no bodies to certify that a
trust has been set up
the only persons who know about the
creation of this agreement are the
trustee and the settler there's no
obligation to register it there is no
financial reporting obligation of trusts
they are not required to put annual
statements
onto account anywhere so actually trusts
are to all intents and purposes
invisible arrangements
economist john christensen was an
economic advisor to the secrecy
jurisdiction of jersey for 10 years
we're not talking about a few million
we're talking now about trillions
trillions of dollars of capital which
apparently belong to nobody for tax
purposes and for other purposes they
belong to nobody
everything works of arts gold bullion
horse resources
cars real estate not just financial
assets but a whole load of non-financial
assets belong to these trusts
sitting there belonging to nobody
now think that one through but we are
talking about maybe as much as 50
trillion dollars
of assets sitting offshore behind these
instruments
well the cayman islands are among
several british overseas territories who
have signed a new information exchange
agreement with britain and the rest of
europe to tackle tax evasion the
countries are now required to
automatically provide details of the
ownership of bank accounts and how
they're used cayman became the first
signatory last week it's important that
the cayman islands should be recognized
as the first overseas territory to sign
such an agreement with the united
kingdom
and i think this importantly reflects
the constructive approach that the
cayman islands has taken
in delivering our shared objective of
rooting out tax evasion
[Music]
the trust lies at the core of the
british secrecy model they don't use
banking secrecy the swiss used banking
secrecy the british of course are only
too willing to kill a banking secrecy
because they will then capture a larger
market share that's why the brits are
doing this
[Music]
trusts are the basic building block of
anglo-saxon secrecy
and they form the basis from which
complex offshore structures are created
every secrecy jurisdiction offers a
specific set of services
from trusts to shell companies to secret
bank accounts and nominee directors
the combination of these services into
complex structures spanning multiple
jurisdictions
enables the creation of secrecy
structures that are almost impossible to
penetrate
an offshore structure will often have a
trust kind of sitting at the top of it
the trust will be here managing the
assets kind of controlling the assets
underneath it the trust will own
some shell companies
each one might be in a different
joystick so you might have a trust in
one jurisdiction whose trustees are
somewhere else
whose beneficiaries are somewhere else
which owns
offshore companies somewhere else each
of these companies might then own assets
so that they might own you know a bank
account
a racehorse a yacht a painting a
portfolio of shares or whatever
there are numerous variations of trusts
and offshore secrecy structures
there are offshore lawyers whose work
entails the creation of ever more
complex and obscure structures
the aim of these structures is to hide
the identity of the owners of offshore
assets and allow offshore wealth to be
recycled back into global markets
looking
on the amount of money
being
administrated from
tax heavens
you see that it is a curb going like
this
and all the talking we have been doing
along with other wonderful people
fighting against tax servants has not
changed anything you know it is the
world where you say go on talking and go
on talking you're interesting me and i'm
going on doing what i want to do we know
everything today because we have had the
panama papers we have seen it
and we are not able to act upon it
and
we are not able to act upon it
because
this system is really protecting
the few people that are
having benefit from it
and these are in person touch very few
people but they are powerful
and i see in the panama committee that
i'm sitting in the only thing
that could change this
is to have a public
accessible register
of the beneficial ownership
of trusts
and of all kind of companies it is easy
the panama papers are a collection of
leaks from the offshore law firm mossack
fonseca
mossack fonseca is the fourth largest
offshore law firm
the other nine of the ten largest
offshore law firms are registered in
british overseas jurisdictions
when countries complain to britain about
the activities run out of its offshore
havens
britain claims that these places are
independent and that there is nothing it
can do
i've heard time and time again from
officials in berlin and in paris and
washington and in other countries
that they've been told by the british
government that
yes they're well aware of what's going
on in jersey and they think it's very
unfortunate but they don't have the
powers to intervene
well that's a straightforward lie they
do have the powers to intervene they
just choose not to
britain plays this kind of game of um
pretending
when it suits them to pretend that these
places are independent
at the end of the day britain appoints
the governor appoints lots of senior
people in these places
they're responsible for foreign
relations and defence and also they can
veto their legislation as well so
britain has a massive degree of control
basically it is controlling these places
allowing them a little bit of political
space
during his time as economic advisor to
jersey
john christensen frequently traveled to
london for talks with various british
government departments
as economic advisor
i had a lot of contact with different
departments
traditionally
uk governments have tried not to
interfere in the domestic affairs of
places like jersey so it happens in a
more subtle sort of way you can go and
talk to someone either the home office
or the treasury and they'd say we're not
actually particularly keen on this piece
of legislation it might be a good idea
if you
didn't go down that route
and over a cup of tea that's quite a
strong signal that's a signal go back to
the island and say they don't want you
to do this
[Music]
the british government prefers not to
interfere overtly
instead it communicates its desires
through informal discussions
there is no paper trail or official
statement
discussions take place behind closed
doors
the relationship that these places have
with london is is very much um
about the british establishment and
people understanding each other i mean
anybody who knows who is british or
knows
british british people
knows that communication between us is
often very subtle and
you have to kind of
know the codes
when people say stuff i mean a lot of
irony involved and um a lot of um
kind of codified language the british
establishment that um people kind of
understand how it works
and i think that is very much the case
with the british relationship with the
tax havens i think there's a lot of
understanding of what we can and can't
do without anyone having to actually
spell it out
by keeping its power hidden
britain is able to claim that these
jurisdictions are politically autonomous
independence for cayman is not on
government's agenda that's the message
being said to the un special committee
on decolonization attorney steve mcphee
will be representing government at the
un meeting the committee was set up to
help colonies around the world on the
road to independence but mr mcfield says
he'll be making it clear that cayman is
not ready for that transition
and that message is that
the premier his cabinet his party
has no mandate from the people of the
cayman islands to seek independence that
is the message that i will be carrying
when the bahamas declared independence
from britain in 1967
the offshore bankers relocated to the
cayman islands and continued their
business from there
it was the british connection that
reassured bankers and their clients that
their money was safe
this british bedrock that is what has
allowed these places to become so
trusted by the financial services
industry and offshore finance and all
these people
in reality
much of the wealth administered in
britain's offshore havens is controlled
from london
the city of london by and large likes to
do its really dirty work
outside london they might heaven forbid
be a regulator who actually takes the
job seriously and starts to prosecute
them for fraud
in london so better to do the frauds
gibraltar or jersey
where there's much less risk that a
serious prosecution will ever happen
deals are often discussed and concluded
in london but then registered offshore
for tax transparency and regulatory
purposes
what they allow the city to do is to get
involved in dirty business
but then when the scandal hits
to say well they're kind of independent
there's nothing we can do about those
places that's that's not us that's
that's tax haven activity and we're
we're the city you know we're not
involved in that kind of stuff so it's
an incredibly kind of convenient
relationship
the city of london
has shaped
the
the way in which
jersey guernsey
and the british overseas territories
have developed as tax havens
i see these places the frankensteins
created by
by the city of london
today
the uk is the world's largest provider
of international financial services
the uk has an almost unique role in
global finance
and if you look at
data
the kind of data that we've constructed
in the financial secrecy index you can
see the relative shares of each country
in
the global provision of financial
services exports that's financial
services to non-residents
now there are two big centers
and everything else is quite small in
comparison
the two large centres of the united
states with around 19 percent of the
global market
and the united kingdom and its offshore
jurisdictions which have around 25 of
the global market
and if you add to that
other jurisdictions
ex-colonies but recently independent
fairly recently
by which i mean hong kong
singapore
maybe even dubai and bahrain
and cyprus
then you reached a figure of nearly 40
percent
and i think that figure represents
better
the position of london in the global
financial market
the soldiers left the administrators
left all the colonies but
they still kept a significant degree of
control over the financial flows from
these former
um the former parts of empire and the
rest of the world so you could describe
it as a second empire britain's second
empire sort of hidden financial empire
spanning large parts of the globe
at the time of the british empire the
city of london was the world's largest
global financial centre
not only britain's colonies but also
independent countries did their banking
in london and use the empire's currency
for trade and financing
as the empire declined
so too did the city of london
the establishment of the london euro
market enabled city of london banks to
continue to exploit their empire era
networks and expertise
and the creation of secrecy
jurisdictions gave banks access to large
amounts of cheap money
international banks from across the
globe set up branches in london and
britain's offshore jurisdictions in
order to take advantage of this new
system
this system has taken the place
of the occupation
i mean up till 62
for france i don't know for england but
about the same time england were
physically present in india for instance
or in
in
other colonies
and when you look at the money flows
through
the tax heavens
they are increasing when we withdraw
from the colonies
we
are still plundering developing
countries as former colonial powers
wealthy individuals organized crime and
corporations shifted their wealth
offshore in exchange for secrecy and no
tax
and as countries around the world began
to deregulate and open their economies
it became ever easier to do so
today as much as half of all global
offshore wealth may be hidden in
britain's secrecy jurisdictions
one of the losers is africa
whose flight capital flows mostly into
the modern british spiders web
i think it's no coincidence that
britain's offshore
empire
emerged more or less at the same time
as the collapse of the formal empire
we tend to think of africa as being a
huge
net debtor to the rest of the world
but
that was the extent of their debts at
the end of 2008 177 billion
the debt of sub-saharan african nations
stood at 177 billion dollars in 2008.
yet the wealth these countries elites
had moved offshore between 1970 and 2008
is estimated at
944 billion dollars
over five times their foreign debt
944 billion dollars
do the maths
far from being a net debtor
africa sub-saharan africa is a net
credit to the rest of the world
as capital moved offshore
african nations borrowed money from
international banks at high interest
over time these debts became so great
that they may never be repaid
secrecy jurisdictions were starving
developing nations of their wealth and
their tax revenues
for a long time a lot of developing
countries including recently ecuador
have been trying to set up a u.n
tax body which is of a higher value than
what is currently there which is the u.n
tax committee and every time this has
happened it has gotten blocked during
the financing for development process in
addis ababa last year
i think it was the uk and the u.s that
blocked attempts again to set up this
world tax organization
so
why would they not want to have
democratic decision making
in global decisions on how tax gets
collected across borders i don't
understand this as long as we have
cross-border activity that involves both
criminal and legal activity as long as
we're unable to separate the two this is
going to continue to be a problem
western nations block attempts to
provide greater transparency of
international financial flows and the
implementation of global standards for
the collection of tax across borders
whilst elites in developing nations use
offshore centres to hide their wealth
offshore
the oil from gabon has not benefited
people in gabon
and this is true for the copper in
zambia for the for the
gold in mozambique or in mali
they have benefited the
company that to extract it
and their shareholders
it has benefited the corrupt elite in
the country in developing countries
the offshore system of tax havens has
facilitated the looting of these
countries by their elites
it has enabled them to steal the money
and keep it safe somewhere else illicit
financial flows
because
the anonymity that drives them
creates incentives for people in
positions of power to be corrupt this is
why there's a group of countries where
development progress is so difficult
it's
that the incentives of individuals and
the ability to pursue them through all
the mechanisms that underpin this it
flows
outweigh
the type of mechanisms that in that lead
you to a powerful representative
effective state that can start to
deliver development
[Music]
worldwide developing countries lose over
a trillion dollars every year in capital
flight and tax evasion
most of this wealth flows into large
western nations like the united states
and britain and enables their currencies
to stay strong
whilst developing nations currencies
remain weak
but illicit flows into western nations
also had another unexpected side effect
the economies of the united states and
britain began to financialize
the origins of this financialization or
de-industrialization
go back to the 1960s
anti-war demonstrators protest u.s
involvement in the vietnam war in mass
marches rallies and demonstrations
president johnson meanwhile let it be
known that the fbi is closely watching
all anti-war activity
in the 1960s u.s economist michael
hudson was working at chase manhattan
bank on wall street as chase's balance
of payments economist during the 1960s
the united states
balance of payments deficit was entirely
a result of foreign military
expenditures
dollars were flowing out of the united
states as a result of the cost of the
vietnam war
the united states attempted to prevent
the dollars flowing to vietnam from
being deposited in foreign banks
the government asked chase to set up a
branch in saigon during the vietnam war
as you can imagine it didn't have
windows it was sort of a fortress it
lost money but the government
went to chase because it said if you
don't get this
money that's being thrown off by the
military in vietnam then it's going to
go into french banks it'll get to
general de gaulle and you know what he's
going to do every month he's going to
cash it in for gold that's what the
united states was trying to stop
the us was not successful in stopping
the outflow of money
so it began to hatch a different plan
in 1967 michael hudson was handed a memo
by a former state department employee in
1967
i was given by a former state department
employee
in the elevator at chase manhattan a
memo from the state department urging
the chase manhattan would uh take the
lead in helping the united states become
the switzerland of the world meaning the
flight capital the state department
through chase asked me to estimate how
much money do you think is available if
america were to become the new
switzerland and how do we do it
the plan was to organize offshore
banking centers in the caribbean and
elsewhere and the hot money wouldn't
come directly into chase because that
wouldn't be
nice and very legal what happened was
that
the latin american criminals other
criminals drug dealers all sorts of
organized crime would put their money in
the offshore caribbean banks and these
offshore banks would then
deposit the inflow in the head office
by moving offshore dollars back into the
united states the u.s was able to stop
the outflow of dollars and support the
value of its currency
every country looks to its foreign
exchange rate and uh the foreign
exchange rate is not only imports and
exports it's capital movements uh and if
you look at the international monetary
funds uh monthly international financial
statistics uh you have sort of a steady
balance of trade a steady immigrants
remittances what goes up and down are
called errors and omissions uh what the
united nations and uh the imf call
errors and omissions are flight capital
it's the uh the reason that it's omitted
is uh they don't like to really look at
this now in the 1930s
roy ovid hall economist for the u.s
commerce department wanted to include uh
criminal movements in the balance of
payment statistics and uh congress got
very upset
i i was told in washington the cut the
argument was we're a christian country
we don't want to report crime it's just
don't look at it
and they they forbid him to uh include
criminal money in the balance of
payments i guess now you call it errors
and omissions you don't call it criminal
inflow and outflow
in the 1960s and 70s
britain was faced with a similar dilemma
as the united states
money was flowing out and this decreased
the value of the pound
britain realized that it too could
support the value of its currency by
opening its domestic markets to the
trillions of dollars passing through its
offshore havens
but just as in the united states
this had an unexpected side effect
the british banks
today
just as in the 19th century don't put
their money into a british manufacturing
they put their money into real estate
speculation into financial speculation
foreign currency trade
so
the financialization of london has
helped de-industrialize the country
because it's enabled uh sterling to be
supported by this huge inflow of hot
money this inflow of drug dealing money
and criminal money and tax evasion money
all over the world uh that is going to
london instead of going to switzerland
liechtenstein or the caribbean
with the silent backing of the united
states
britain's offshore havens grew rapidly
and before long the offshore system
developed into the world's dominant
international financial market
few were aware how this market
functioned
in 1986 economist john christensen went
offshore to investigate
he applied for a position at the jersey
office of one of the world's major
accounting firms
my delight in touch i was um i was
working what's called company and trust
administration straightforward offshore
stuff
i went off shop specifically to work in
that area because that's where you're
dealing with the offshore companies the
shell companies the offshore trusts and
you're administering them that way i
could i could see from working inside
a big global accounting firm exactly
what the clients were doing
i had complete access to all the client
files
and over the course of my period of
working with deloitte touch
i investigated over a hundred of their
clients offshore
and this is what i found
there were some insider traders some
market rigging some avoiding disclosure
of conflicts of interest illicit arms
trading illicit political campaign
donations contract kickbacks bribery
fraudulent invoicing trade miss pricing
and at the bottom tax evasion
okay
this
is what the clients were doing
the basis of a sample of the clients
that i looked at not a single client was
involved in what i would regard as
genuinely legitimate activity they were
all involved in some kind of tax dodging
or
worse
i met with
carl levin he used to be an american
senator
and he made a lot of inquiries
into private banking asking questions to
the bankers
what do you think
the percentage is among your clients
that are using these companies for
legitimate purposes
and the answer was
i believe that
99.9 percent of my clients are using
these companies for illicit purposes
this is a reality this is american
bankers telling what they are doing and
it's exactly the same thing with
uk bankers
helping their clients to have accounts
in panama or in bermuda or in caiman
islands
[Music]
secrecy jurisdictions are heavily used
for fraudulent and grey area financial
activities
areas where secrecy is not just
desirable but a necessity
legitimate financial activity has no
need for the secrecy offshore havens
provide
nor a desire to pay the high fees
offshore banks and law firms charge
today close to half of the world's
secrecy jurisdictions are british
dependencies
in public these jurisdictions claim they
are transparent and their financial
services sectors are engaged in
legitimate financial activities
our economy is not based on secrecy it's
uh
it's based on transparency it's based on
a sound regulatory environment
uh it's based on good governance and
good government
with a british government
legal system that's what our
financial institutions are based on
well tonight we have a response from the
head of cayman finance after a group of
u.s based anti-tax evasion activists
announced plans to travel to cayman to
draw attention to what they feel is
corporate tax evasion finance chairman
mr richard cole says he's encouraging
the group to visit and says our
financial sector has nothing to hide
i would say if anybody wants to come to
cayman to find out what what's coming
you know what we do here come on down
we have no secrets here
when i went to the cayman islands um
back in
2008 i think it was i called the
government spokesman he said okay we
have had an order from on high that
nobody is allowed to speak to you you
are off limits
in 2011
journalist nicholas jackson released
treasure islands a groundbreaking book
about the offshore system
the author of a series of international
media reports says he would welcome a
debate with cayman finance chair tony
travers mr travers recently called
nicholas jackson an imbecile with the
understanding of of an 11 year old there
are always going to be the politics of
envy now the politics of envy are
exacerbated by
uh imbeciles who don't actually
understand what's going on in the cayman
islands i don't know what he's talking
about and furthermore he doesn't know
what he's talking about
the cayman islands is the fifth largest
financial center in the world
it hosts 80 000 registered companies
over three quarters of the world's hedge
funds
and 1.9 trillion dollars in deposits
it has a population of sixty thousand
roughly equivalent to new york's
homeless population
a strange mixture of characters populate
the offshore world
british ex-public school boys
members of the world's intelligence
services
global criminals assorted lords and
ladies
and bankers galore
[Music]
with so much at stake for so many
wealthy and powerful individuals it may
come as no surprise that britain's
offshore havens have developed their own
curious mechanisms to prevent
information from leaking out
for many people
who work offshore
and who don't like what they're doing
it's very hard indeed to dissent because
they will be attacked personally with a
degree of viciousness which is quite
extraordinary
most of the time the instruments of
suppression are relatively sophisticated
you won't get promotion by doing this or
your family
won't like it
it's not generally let's slam them in
prison that's far too crude we are
talking about
very substantially you know the
establishment the british establishment
in these cases the the mechanisms are
very very subtle sort of ostracism is is
one way of doing it um these peculiar
mechanisms for you know if someone tries
to to blow the whistle you find all
sorts of methods that aren't
the most you know just fire them you
give them far too much work to do you
steer them in a different direction
one person who is intimately familiar
with how suppression works offshore
is former jersey senator and health
minister stuart sivray
in 2009 he leaked a report on a rogue
nurse suspected of killing patients at
jersey's hospital
it all came to a head during a state's
debate on tuesday the 10th of march
senator stuart sivrey brought the
sitting to a standstill claiming senator
jimmy perchard had sworn at him and told
him to go and top himself senator
pershard denied the claim saying i
absolutely refute that but less than a
week later he was forced to admit he had
lied senator pershard has now admitted
that on another occasion he did tell
senator stuart sivray to go and do
everyone a favor and slit his wrists
i was
arrested at my house one morning by
six plainclothes police officers there
were another two specialist
data search police officers on hand and
also another two police officers in full
body armor of one of those battering
rams they're kind of using drugs rates
so 10 police officers descended on me
without a without a search warrant the
property was turned over from top to
bottom all the computers were seized and
searched all kinds of private
constituency data was stolen by the
police
shortly after we began filming
a police officer exited the police
station
as he hurried past he grinned at the
camera
the officer was on his way to test the
sirens on his motorbike which he did at
intervals throughout much of the
remainder of the interview
when it came to prosecuting me
stuart sivray was prosecuted under the
data protection law
now when the authorities were
prosecuting me i claimed that this was a
legitimate public interest disclosure
defence and i with an expert witness was
able to produce a set of reports that
effectively destroyed
the prosecution case
[Music]
in reaction to this
the magistrates ruled that stuart
sivray's defense case that he had leaked
the report in the public interest would
no longer be admissible
but continued to prosecute him all the
same without a defense case
over the past seven years stuart sivrey
has been repeatedly taken to court and
imprisoned three times
he does not know when or if the
persecution will end
nor does he know when he will find
himself behind bars again
to look at jersey from the outside it
looks like it's got a prosecution system
it looks like it's got a court
and a legislature
but none of it's real it's a potemkin
village none of these systems in jersey
meet the tests of being objective
of being objective or actually
functioning properly the experience that
stuart sivrey had
is you know
he's perhaps at the at the blunder end
of the scale you know he was simply
suppressed
and taken to court on trumped up charges
they'll carry on being let's carry on
trying to do the interview they might
get
[Music]
bored this is the kind of this is kind
of how oppression happens in jersey
all kinds of little things
get done to harass people you know even
they don't often go to the kind of
extremes they did against me in terms of
actually arresting me and putting me in
prison but
the authorities use all kinds of other
lesser little
methods to interfere with people kind of
sabotage things you know
obstruct people make life difficult for
people you know if you annoy the
establishment in jersey you won't get a
job here
you know you know your children won't
get decent jobs you know that's kind of
how it works you know
i went to jersey in march 2009 with with
nick jackson about 24 hours after we
arrived in jersey we were there for
several days nick said did you know that
have you noticed that we're being
followed ever since we arrived in at the
airport
we've been followed he said don't look
now but
we're being followed now
turns out he was quite correct we were
being followed
and i found that
very disturbing very disturbing indeed
they have a saying in jersey
if you don't like it here there's always
a boat in the morning
jersey finance promotional literature
states jersey represents an extension of
the city of london
it's where the city of london chooses to
do many of the activities which they
couldn't do in london itself
we're here to talk about this one
company called applebee i just read what
they say on their website
members of the firm appleby have gone on
not only to political office but also in
a number of centres bermuda jersey the
island and cayman islands to senior
judicial office
so essentially they're boasting of the
fact that their staff and their partners
have a real interchange between the
people that are in power in these
offshore financial centers
the same lawyers and accountants who set
up and administer offshore trusts also
occupy senior political positions
in britain's offshore world most
politicians are in business
they lobby for business and promote
business interests
they draft refine and pass legislation
politicians sit on the boards of the
companies they are supposed to regulate
there is no place for dirty money in
britain
indeed there should be no place for
dirty money anywhere the challenge i'm
laying down for every country today is
to root out the rot of corruption to
ensure transparency over what your own
companies are doing
require transparency for foreign
companies in your country too
and work with us to spread this approach
to transparency around the world
in public british politicians claim they
are cracking down on secrecy
jurisdictions and corruption
but in practice they do the opposite
when i talk to politicians in brussels
they say that they've had more
lobbyists
from
london
and including politicians
come to them to protect the city of
london's interests than they've had from
every other european member state
combined which gives you some idea of
the extent to which
british politicians see themselves as
essentially lobbyists for the city of
london
we begin with our big story cayman's
efforts to ensure transparency in its
financial services sector is being
recognized by the international
community earlier this week the uk's
prime minister david cameron told
parliament that the tax haven label
placed on its crown dependencies and
overseas territories is unfair
many british politicians have personal
and business ties with the city of
london and british secrecy jurisdictions
former british prime minister david
cameron's father ian cameron was an
expert in offshore funds and was
involved in offshore trusts from the
1980s onwards
at this courthouse behind me here in
cinehelia we found this it's a document
called a grant of probate and it's
attached to the english will of none
other than ian cameron david cameron's
father stay here
[Applause]
ian cameron was certainly a wealthy man
in 2009 his personal fortune was
estimated by researchers for the sunday
times rich list at 10 million pounds yet
when ian cameron died in 2010 his estate
was much smaller than might be expected
just 2.7 million pounds
in many cases it's the politicians and
their cronies and their families and so
on and the business people who sponsor
the political parties who are using
these offshore services themselves so so
they got no personal interest in closing
it down if they wanted to close it down
they could do it tomorrow the fact of
the matter is they don't want to do it
because they themselves are complicit
with the process
if you come from the same kind of
background you know the right people
then all the kind of legal niceties
will will often fall away you can get
away with doing all sorts of things that
they wouldn't just let any old person
you know if you came knocking on the
door saying can you set up an offshore
company to do this they tell you to get
lost but
if you're part of the networks you can
you can do these kinds of things so
that's a very important part of the um
part of the whole system upper class
british public school kind of
establishment that has been there since
you know for centuries
the british establishment an old boy's
network of privileged elites had carved
out a lucrative niche for themselves in
the offshore world after the demise of
empire
they transformed themselves from
administrators of empire into financial
handlers for the global elite and
multinational corporations
as more money flowed offshore
societies around the globe began to feel
the impact of the offshore world
the reality is not
what you believe that
your prime minister has the power to
to decide on the future of your country
the power is hidden here
we have country after country around the
world where the lack of financial
transparency about taxation about
ownership about corruption
has undermined the extent to which
governments deliver representative
policy making for their citizens you
know we have extreme cases like the the
hiding of
um tax evasion by
people in finance ministries in greece
in france
but we also have this system that in
general is geared towards anonymous
company ownership the anonymous
ownership of properties across london of
half of the land in scotland you know do
we really think that any circumstances
in which governments work better in
which markets work better in which the
distribution of income and assets is
better when we allow so much to be
hidden who wants to not know who you're
doing business with who wants their
government to have
people working for it or to be led by
people whose assets are hidden whose
financial transactions
are conducted anonymously offshore
this is a bad direction for the world we
need the citizens to understand what is
happening that they are the ones who is
carrying the burden
and that
some individuals having the power
are exonerating themselves ordinary
people are paying taxes
rich people are not
so this is
inequality
and it is leading up to populism because
it shows so clearly that the people
today leading the world
are not able to take care of the
interest of ordinary people
back in the 60s and 70s you know
tax evasion or pushing back against
taxation it was kind of seen as
anti-establishment so you know the
rolling stones and um phil collins all
these people kind of going offshore
going away
it was seen as a sort of rebellious
thing to do and if you fast forward to
the present day um
now that is the establishment the
offshore system is the establishment
today
offshore is the way elites and
multinational corporations conduct their
affairs
tax evasion is the way business is done
this kind of sophisticated cheating
requires a huge infrastructure
we like to talk about the pinstripe
infrastructure of highly educated people
who think it is their right to help
others to cheat societies
we have a new mafia in town it does not
actually shoot people does not put
bullets in their kneecaps but this trade
is just as deadly it deprives people
of opportunities to have health care
education
security justice
and essentially
a fulfilling life
accountants form the backbone of the
offshore system
they administer the structures that
allow individuals and corporations to
shift their money offshore and evade
taxes
there are about 2.5 million
professionally qualified accountants on
this planet
about 330 000 are in the uk
well-known people well-dressed well-fed
highly paid are sitting in city center
offices and they are paid to dream up
tax avoidance schemes for individuals
and for corporations
we can all elect a government
which says vote for us we will give you
better health care better education
better security
and next they account and say sorry
about that folks you elected this
government but we actually got a tax
avoidance scheme and the amazons and the
google that microsoft won't be paying
any taxes in your jurisdiction too bad
you voted for it but actually you're
going to get something else so it's a
crazy world that part of the business
model at big accountancy firms is how to
deny public the services by erosion
of
tax revenues and these firms are then
rewarded with government-funded
contracts and the same firms are then
advising
local governments and the central
governments and the same firms then
report on the company accounts and tell
us all is well when i argue this with a
price waterhouse partner in a
face-to-face debate he said professor
sicker you never give us credit for
anything we generate millions of dollars
of revenues
and we have lots and lots of satisfied
clients what is your problem
and my response is very simple that's
the language of drug pushers and pimps
[Music]
in britain a new breed of civil servant
was rising to the top
one such civil servant was dave hartnett
who rose to the top of hmrc the uk tax
authority
dave hartnett had a new way of
collecting tax
deals would be negotiated on an
individual basis behind closed doors
in the case of the largest clients dave
hartnett frequently led the negotiations
himself
british telecom was one of the first
companies through the program and
received a refund of over one billion
pounds
bt's chief executive ben favain wrote
earnings per share up 14
and nice to know that we have a one
billion pound credit from the tax man
dave hartnett claimed this approach was
more efficient
litigation in the courts is really
phenomenally expensive
in this day and age all over the world
and i think it's to be avoided where
possible
and the art is to persuade people to pay
by strength of argument and the like
[Music]
after protests erupted in 2011
the treasury select committee questioned
dave hartnett
dave hartnett claimed he could not give
any information due to taxpayer
confidentiality
reporting statute prevents
you from disclosing information to
parliament
all my advice mr barclay so far has been
that
i am prevented and my colleagues are
prevented
by the act and by the decision of the
commissioners
dave hartnett failed to mention that the
legal advice he had received stated that
the disclosure of information was at the
discretion of the head of hmrc
the head of hmrc was dave hartnett
himself
just like the mafia has penetrated the
state accountancy firms have also
penetrated the state the head of
anti-avoidance in the uk
tax authority
is from one of these firms
the newly appointed chairman of her
majesty's revenue and customs which is a
tax authority is a partner from kpmg
their partners have penetrated the state
they are running the treasury
britain's financial services industry
had penetrated the state
and began to shape its laws for its own
benefit
the degree of capture political capture
by the city of london by the big banks
and the big law firms is so enormous
that the politicians have effectively
become their spokespersons
with the government unwilling to act in
the interest of the public
a group of protesters confronted dave
hartnett at a private event in oxford
hi everybody i'm sorry to interrupt a
few moments of your time
here tonight to present today with an
award it is the lifetime achievement
award for services to corporate tax
planning
[Applause]
a great friend to many of us over the
years and you know really we just can't
thank you enough for what he's done
obviously it wasn't vodafone um you know
it saved us billions
off our tax bill and our friends at
goldman sachs as well we've also saved
us millions 20 to 25 million these
people are trespassers and intruders and
i know you've had problems
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
after his retirement
dave hartnett moved to the private
sector
one of his positions was at accountancy
firm deloitte
where he advises foreign governments on
corporate taxation
dave hartnett is a companion of the
order of the bath
an honour bestowed on him by the british
monarch
we have former
ministers acting as advisers to
accountancy firms accountancy firms
provide jobs and consultancies for
potential ministers to my mind really
it's an indication of corrupt structures
people are buying and selling influences
when a former minister works for an
accountancy firm is not providing any
accounting that knowledge is opening
political opportunities
home and abroad that is what they are
doing i hope by now
you'll share my view that i don't trust
most bankers i don't trust most lawyers
i don't trust most accounting firms i
actually think they're engaged in a
conspiracy against public interest
in britain secrecy and complexity in
finance and government help to obscure
corruption in public office
financial structures are often so
complex that even after they are
publicly revealed they are not widely
recognized for what they are
an example of this is pfi
the private finance initiative
pfi is private finance initiative it is
a way of funding public infrastructure
things like hospitals schools
roads and bridges but financing them via
the private sector rather than the
historical method which is via central
government
over a period of 30 or 40 years
the amounts of kind of repayment costs
will be sort of three or four times
higher overall than if you borrowed it
from central government in the first
place so it's basically a giant
accounting scam
once the pfi policy has been set up
you find that the big four accountancy
firms were actually
paid members of staff within the
treasury department who were then
actually going around and selling and
advising upon the
implementation of pfi contracts by
public authorities
the effectively saying come to us and we
will show you how to derive the most
benefit from it in other words how to
perhaps exploit the legislation even the
offices
of the state tax authority on our own
offshore
hmrc which is the the tax collector here
in the uk
their offices
are owned
in bermuda
by a company called mapley steps
it's quite incredible
the company that owns the pfi contract
to run hmrc's head office
borrowed money from offshore investors
at 15
interest
because the interest was so high the
company was losing money
therefore it did not pay tax
in 2011
hmrc could not prove that any pfi
company was paying any tax in the uk
i think we'd have a serious conversation
about the the role of government in this
whole debacle and how much our
government has been penetrated by big
banks and accountancy firms and
ultimately in whose interest it operates
the reason we were protesting outside
the africa ppp conference is that we
wanted to make sure that citizens back
in africa
should hear about the fact that such
policies have been a complete failure
here in the uk we know that these
products are not being marketed to
african countries in their own best
interests the only motivation is to
spread the reach of financial services
into new markets it's all been promoted
in the interest of the city of london
what you're seeing is basically a second
form of colonialization you've had
initially occupation resource extraction
um you know and
through that process you know countries
like britain which have had a large
offshore empire have developed
significant networks and there are those
networks being used to promote and
exploit financial services
the city of london was the beating
financial heart of the british empire
as britain's empire declined the city
transformed itself from a hub operating
the financial machinery of empire
into a global financial centre
former insignificant outposts of empire
became the basis for a spider's web of
offshore secrecy jurisdictions that
captured wealth from across the globe
and funneled it to the city of london
[Music]
today
25 percent of international finance is
conducted on british territory
almost half of the world's secrecy
jurisdictions are under british
protection
up to half of all offshore wealth may be
hidden in britain's offshore havens
[Music]
financial services is how britain's
elites make their money
and it is also where former government
ministers senior civil servants and
retired spooks from mi5 and mi6
receive lucrative consulting positions
after their time in public service
together they have transformed britain
and its dependencies into the world's
largest tax haven
harming development throughout the world
and turning britain itself into a
country that serves above all the
interests of its elites
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you